I was so inspired by all the Renaissance art in Florence
I thought I'd take a drawing class
at the Accademia d'Arte e Italiano.
Oh, here we go.
(laughter)
That's the nude man.
Our model, yeah.
Apollon.
Yes.
He's wearing flip flops.
When I think of great drawings
I don't think of a man wearing flip flops.
When I look at great statues, say of Apollo, Zeus,
(laughter)
I don't see flip flops.
I draw the oval of the head.
How's that look?
[Apollon] Okay, that's okay, yeah.
Lot of chest hair in here I see.
It's time to address--I've not addressed
his genitalia, his penis.
Of course there's the shaft right here,
and then there's the testicle or testes here.
I've drawn it too big there.
Doing the guy a favor frankly.
I'm giving him about a 20% markup.
(laughter)
His girlfriend will thank me later.
And then there's this hair here.
I'm what we call a narcissist in America.
You know what a narcissist is?
Always end up drawing myself.
And then of course the penis gets bigger because it's me.
Goes down to here.
Much bigger penis.
And some freckles.
I usually wear a suit when I'm on television.
I think I'm going to put myself--I'm on a bus.
Yeah, I'm on a bus traveling.
People are looking in as they wait to board the bus.
Do you mind if I bring in a model with less hair?
[Apollon] Sure.
This is Jordan.
Hello, sir.
I think a pose would be appropriate.
Hitchhiking, you're hitching a ride and you're naked.
This is called "Naked Man Looking for a Ride."
Can you give me one of these?
(groaning)
That's good.
This is called "Mentally Ill Man Attacks."
Miss, no laughing here, please.
We can't have laughing.
We see here the deadness in the eyes.
There's no soul, the man has no soul.
There's just nothing in there.
And then legs sort of like a frog,
but a frog that's very sickly.
See, they're bent like a frog-
Excuse me.
Because you told me to bend them like a frog.
Excuse me, excuse me.
Models mustn't speak.
There's one last pose, if you could face that way.
And then you look back with a jaunty look
as if to say, "Check out my butt."
And give us a thumbs up.
(laughter)
Apollon, I wanna thank you.
Jordan, I've sold your clothes.
(laughter)
Thought you did a nice job.
(cheering and applause)
Wanna get a bite to eat?